i
ya son diez las capitales de provincia
capturadas por el grupo talibán los
insurgentes invadieron gas cni que se
encuentra a tan sólo 150 km de kabul la
inteligencia estadounidense estima que
la capital del país podría caer en manos
de los talibanes en cuestión de 90 días
no deja de arder la región del
mediterráneo argelia que ya registra 69
muertos por los incendios inició este
jueves su día sus tres días de luto
nacional
italia registró un récord de 48.8 grados
centígrados en sicilia y las tormentas y
era un respiro a grecia donde más de 100
mil hectáreas han sido consumidas
australia con fino este jueves por siete
días a su capital canberra de sus
comunidades aledañas tras detectar un
caso de kobe 19 el primero en 13 meses
mientras tanto su vecino nueva zelanda
anunció la reapertura gradual de sus
fronteras para personas vacunadas en
2022 según un esquema basado en
categorías de riesgo
muy buenos días gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france 24 o sea blanco
como siempre un gusto acompañarlos
comenzamos con el avance relámpago de
los talibanes en afganistán la principal
ciudad de la provincia de ghazni en el
sur de ese país se convirtió hoy jueves
en la décima capital regional en caer en
manos de los talibanes en los últimos
siete días los insurgentes tomaron la
mayoría de los edificios gubernamentales
incluida la casa del gobernador la sede
de la policía y la mayoría de las sedes
oficiales este jueves francés suspendió
la expulsión de migrantes afganos
alemania y países bajos habían adoptado
una medida similar veamos el informe
un grito de victoria de los talibanes en
la ciudad de ghazni
a 150 km al suroeste de kabul es la
décima capital de provincia que cae en
las manos de los insurgentes su ofensiva
que comenzó en mayo avanza a un ritmo
desenfrenado pero washington ya no está
haciendo frente a los rebeldes y el
gobierno afgano deberá asegurar su
propia seguridad
continuamos con los ataques aéreos en
apoyo de las fuerzas afganas pero como
ha indicado el presidente de byd en los
dirigentes afganos deben unirse el
futuro de su país descansa en sus
hombros los talibanes ya habían
conseguido tomar el control de la ciudad
de faisalabad en la provincia de
badajshán en la frontera con tayikistán
pakistán y china desde el viernes pasado
los talibanes ha tomado control de estas
10 capitales de provincia y la última de
ellas gas cni por donde pasa una
importante carretera que une kabul con
el sur del territorio el miércoles el
presidente asad cani estuvo en la
asediada ciudad de mazar-i-sharif al
norte intentando coordinar una retoma
mientras tanto en doha qatar avanzan
unas conversaciones para intentar
relanzar un proceso de paz que se
encuentra en punto muerto a la vez
decenas de miles van llegando a kabul y
otros tantos intentan salir del país
desde el comienzo del año más de 390.000
personas han sido desplazadas por el
conflicto en el país con un pico
registrado en mayo de acuerdo con
algunas estimaciones unos dos tercios de
akuan están estarían bajo control
mientras la retirada de las tropas
estadounidenses avanza a gran ritmo y
estaría completa para el 31 de agosto
hablemos ahora de medio ambiente la ola
de calor que se registra en el
mediterráneo está provocando en italia
la semana más cálida del año y las zonas
sur y centro-oeste del país se
encuentran en alerta con temperaturas
que superan los 45 grados la ciudad de
siracusa alcanzó los
48.8 grados cifra que podría suponer un
nuevo récord de calor en europa y
superaría los 48 grados de atenas en el
año 1977 grecia amaneció con tormentas
locales que dieron un respiro a dos
semanas de asfixia por las altas
temperaturas y los incendios que han
consumido más de 100 mil hectáreas
mientras que argelia lucha por cuarto
día consecutivo contra los incendios
focalizados en el norte del país que han
provocado la muerte de 69 personas y
donde hoy iniciaron los 3 días de duelo
nacional decretados por el gobierno
y hasta
hay muchos daños algunos han perdido sus
hogares muchas cosas la naturaleza no se
recupera pronto dado que la gente vivió
aquí de sus cultivos esto es solo el
comienzo del desastre
la gente ha muerto las escuelas y las
casas se han quemado los aldeanos han
abandonado sus hogares para refugiarse
en los dormitorios comunales y las
aldeas comunales y aun el gigantesco
incendio activo desde hace cuatro
semanas en el noreste de california ya
ha destruido más de 550 viviendas y los
bomberos solo tienen contenido un 30%
hasta el momento del incendio dixie
bautizado así por el nombre de la
carretera de montaña junto a la que se
inició lleva calcinadas 200 2.700
hectáreas el fuego es el segundo más
grande jamás registrado en la historia
de ese estado únicamente superado por el
de aguas complex del año pasado
vamos ahora a polonia donde el
parlamento aprobó una controvertida ley
sobre la propiedad de los medios de
comunicación que impediría a las
empresas extranjeras tener una
participación mayoritaria en los medios
de comunicación de ese país la oposición
considera que esta ley amenaza la
libertad de prensa y tensar a las
relaciones con eeuu por su parte la
comisión europea criticó el proyecto
asegurando que envía una señal negativa
un informe de amal benotman
la coalición gobernante de polonia
perdió la mayoría en el parlamento uno
de los partidos de la alianza se retiró
tras una serie de desacuerdos con el
mayoritario ley y justicia sobre varias
reformas
la más reciente es la ley de medios de
comunicación y es que la controversial
iniciativa fue aprobada por un estrecho
margen en el parlamento polaco
228 votos a favor y 216 en contra ley y
justicia introdujo enmiendas para
prohibir a las empresas extranjeras
tener una participación mayoritaria en
la televisión la radio y la prensa
citando china y rúsia el gobierno alega
que es necesario para evitar la
posibilidad de que potencias extranjeras
tuve en el control de los medios polacos
pero los opositores consideran que es un
intento para obligar a la empresa
estadounidense discovery a vender tvn
una cadena de televisión crítica del
gobierno conservador soy el único fed
esta es una ley inconstitucional
diseñada para censurar a los medios de
comunicación libres y es inconsistente
con los tratados internacionales
hoy afecta a una de las estaciones de tv
pero de hecho afecta a la seguridad de
polonia porque no es normal un inversor
ya no querrá invertir en un país donde
en una noche se pueda aprobar una ley
que de facto expulsa al capital de un
país aliado
la ley fue también criticada por eeuu
winfrey sabemos que unos medios de
comunicación libres e independientes
hacen que nuestra democracia sea más
fuerte por eso hemos instado al gobierno
de polonia a que demuestre sus
compromisos con estos principios que son
compartidos no sólo de palabras sino de
hechos y nalón words and printing la
coalición polaca ha sido criticada por
la unión europea por algunas prácticas
que consideran hacen retroceder las
libertades democráticas
y vamos ahora con noticias de la
pandemia de kobe 19 en eeuu california
se ha convertido en el primer estado en
obligar al personal docente a vacunarse
o presentar regularmente un test de kobe
negativo el objetivo proteger a los
menores de 12 años no elegibles para la
vacunación y reforzar la campaña de
inmunización ya que alrededor del país
las reticencias políticas se están
dividiendo la administración de vacunas
con territorios republicanos muy
reticentes al fármaco donde se están
registrando los mayores rebrotes del
virus que ya vuelve a causar más de
100.000 casos diarios la mayoría por la
variante del tratamos el informe
delta ha evidenciado la brecha entre los
dos estados unidos la alta transmisión
de la variante ha provocado un rebrote
de los contagios y hospitalizaciones
principalmente entre la población no
vacunada por un lado los estadounidenses
que todavía no recibieron el fármaco son
los menores de 12 años no son elegibles
para la vacunación y están sufriendo más
esta ola
sabemos que la variante delta se propaga
rápidamente no solo entre adultos
también entre niños y adolescentes
causando la mayoría de los casos que
detectamos a día de hoy y la verdad es
que los niños de menos de 12 años
todavía no tienen acceso a la vacuna
vaccinia
de cara a la vuelta a las aulas tras las
vacaciones california ha impuesto la
vacunación obligatoria para el personal
docente de centros públicos y privados
tras aplicar la misma norma para los
trabajadores de la administración y de
la salud a wifi
de inocentes es este nuevo güey que
creemos que es lo correcto y que es la
manera adecuada de mantener las escuelas
abiertas y responder a los padres
preocupados como yo que tengo cuatro
hijos y eso es que las escuelas hagan
todo lo que está manos para mantener a
los niños a salvo ahora ricky markets
safe
sin embargo california uno de los
territorios más progresistas del país
cuenta ya con un elevado índice de
vacunación en relación a estados
tradicionalmente republicanos la gran
división entre los estadounidenses que
decidieron recibir el fármaco y los que
no es en gran medida partidista según
una encuesta del washington post jay
vice news el 47% de los republicanos son
reticentes a la vacuna mientras que
entre los demócratas la cifra baja al 6%
la polarización política ha encontrado
un nuevo eje de articulación y ha
frustrado el plan de vacunación masiva
con el que bardem llegó a la casa blanca
vamos ahora australia porque cambiará la
capital de ese país se sumó a la lista
de ciudades que entraron en
confinamiento tras detectar un primer
contagio en más de un año nuestro
corresponsal en ese país es camilo
montoya nos cuenta del panorama en
australia que lucha contra los rebrotes
de kobe 19
y más de la mitad de la población de
australia está en confinamiento debido a
rebrote de la variante delta de kobe 19
la última ciudad en sumarse fue cambiar
la capital del país que entra desde hoy
a un confinamiento de 7 días debido a
cuatro casos nuevos registrados en las
últimas 24 horas pero la peor situación
se está viviendo en sydney capital del
estado de nueva gales del sur que a
pesar de llevar más de un mes y medio
con fuertes restricciones no ha podido
disminuir los contagios tiene 5500 casos
activos y un promedio diario de 300
contagios nuevos queensland en este
estado cuya capital en la ciudad de
brisbane tiene un total de 155 casos
activos y un promedio diario de 10 casos
nuevos aquí en melbourne capital del
estado de victoria estamos viviendo el
sexto confinamiento desde que inició la
pandemia y el cuarto este año tenemos un
promedio de 20 casos nuevos diarios y en
total 137 casos activos australia empezó
su proceso de vacunación en febrero y
hasta el momento tiene alrededor del 20
por ciento de su población que el 25
millones vacunada con las dos dosis de
astrazéneca y fisher esta semana el
gobierno federal anunció que se aprobó
la distribución de la vacuna de moderna
que en próxima semana se empezará a
llegar al país y el vecino nueva zelanda
mientras tanto anunció que comenzará a
reabrir sus fronteras a los turistas
vacunados en un plan escalonado que
iniciará el próximo año 2022 se prevé
que las personas provenientes de países
considerados de bajo riesgo y que tengan
el esquema completo de vacunación puedan
ingresar sin necesidad de hacer una
cuarentena estas fueron las palabras de
la primera ministra hasina oren
anteriormente dije que la frontera ha
actuado como una armadura colectiva para
nueva zelanda protegiéndonos contra el
virus
el truco con la vacunación es hacer que
cada uno de nosotros tenga una armadura
individual lo que significa que debemos
depender menos de la frontera las
vacunas son el factor decisivo en esta
pandemia pero para que tenga éxito
necesitamos que se vacune el mayor
número posible de personas
y guadalupe enfrenta restricciones más
estrictas es durante al menos tres
semanas ya que la isla enfrenta una
situación que el presidente francés
semana cron ha calificado el drama
debido a un aumento de los casos de
coronavirus hoy en día casi una de cada
cinco personas son positivas para kobe
19 en territorio francés de ultramar
veamos el informe las calles de punta
pita desiertas antes de la pandemia no
paraba el ajetreo y el bullicio en estas
costas mientras lugareños y turistas se
mezclaban en las estrechas calles sin
embargo tras el aumento de los casos de
kobe 19 guadalupe ha vuelto a entrar en
confinamiento con restricciones aún más
estrictas el toque de queda nocturno
ahora comienza a las 7 de la noche en
lugar de las 8 y va hasta las 5 de la
mañana las personas también están
obligadas a permanecer dentro de un
perímetro de cinco kilómetros alrededor
de su casa y se requerirá un certificado
para demostrar la necesidad de una
actividad al aire libre el único consejo
que puedo dar es que a partir de este
momento todo el mundo debe quedarse en
casa a menos que tenga un motivo
especial durante las próximas tres
semanas tenemos que evitar las
interacciones sociales lo hacemos por
los trabajadores que están en primera
línea además hasta nuevo aviso todas las
tiendas no esenciales permanecerán
cerradas
en las playas solo se permitirán
actividades dinámicas como paseos
natación o deportes individuales también
se han prohibido las actividades
turísticas todo esto al menos hasta el 3
de septiembre y cerramos este noticiero
con música este 12 de agosto se cumplen
30 años del lanzamiento de the black
álbum considerado por muchos como el
disco más importante en la discografía
de la banda de heavy metal
estadounidense metallica
[Música]
el álbum negro que contiene grandes
éxitos de la banda como enter sandman
nothing else matters' o the unforgiven
es uno de los éxitos comerciales más
grandes en la historia del rock al haber
conectado a la música de metallica con
las masas más de 16 millones de copias
han sido vendidas a la fecha para
conmemorar el lanzamiento la agrupación
lanzó una reedición del disco y además
una edición de covers el llamado de
metallica black list al que contribuyen
artistas de diversos géneros musicales
felices 30 años de esta pieza musical
inolvidable
[Música]
y de esta manera ponemos fin al
informativo continuar con nosotras
[Música]